>> ♪ ♪
>> OUR MISSION IN AFGHANISTAN
CONTINUES.
WE CONTINUE TO EXECUTE A SAFE,
DRAW DOWN IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S GUIDANCE AND FOR
U.S. FORCES TO BE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BY THE END OF
AUGUST.
>> WHEN WE WITHDRAW, THE
KILLINGS OF WOMEN AND THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, PRESIDENT
BIDEN WILL ONLY THESE UGLY
IMAGES.
WE WILL GIVE ISIS AND AL-QAEDA
A SAVE HAVEN.
THE VACUUM WILL BE FILLED BY
TERRORISTS.
AM CONCERNED WE WILL BE GOING
BACK.
>> THE VIEW FROM THE TOP
REPUBLICAN AND FROM THE
PENTAGON.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
TREY GOWDY FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
WELCOME.
BILL, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
SITUATION IN AFGHANISTAN?
U.S. TROOPS COMING OUT.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS?
>> I WILL BE BIPARTISAN.
IT'S A DISASTER.
IT WILL BE ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
WATCH BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ENCOURAGING IT TOO.
THIS IS SOUTH ASIA.
WE WILL HAVE NO MAJOR BASE
THERE.
THE BAGRAM AIR FORCE BASE IS
A SUBSTANTIAL BASE AND WE
MONITOR FROM THERE.
THE ROAD FROM CHINA TO EUROPE
GOES RIGHT THROUGH AFGHANISTAN.
WE MADE IT EASIER.
PLUS CONSIDER THE WOMEN.
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL?
I HOPE WE GOT OUT AS MANY PEOPLE
WHO HELPED US AS POSSIBLE.
FINALLY, NOT JUST THE MORAL
VICTORY BUT A REAL VICTORY FOR
THE TALIBAN.
WE CHEERED WHEN THE SOVIETS LEFT
AND NOW WE ARE LEAVING.
THE COMMENTS FROM THE PENTAGON
SOUNDED LIKE SAIGON.
VERY SORRY TO STAY THIS.
THIS IS A DREADFUL AND HUGE
MISTAKE.
>> THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT THE
INTERPRETERS AND THE DRIVERS WHO
HELPED U.S. FORCES.
LET'S PLAY THIS CLIP.
>> THESE ARE INTERPRETERS AND
DRIVERS, PEOPLE WHO WARNED OUR
AMERICAN TROOPS OF THREATS.
WE HAVE TO GET THEM HOME.
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US FOR OUR
ALLIES AND ANY FUTURE ENDEAVORS
TO PROTECT DEMOCRACY.
IF OUR ALLIES CAN'T TRUST TO US
THERE THEIR BACKS LIKE THESE
AFGHANS HAD OUR BACKS IN A 20
YEAR WAR, WE CAN'T PROJECT OUR
DEMOCRATIC VALUES ACROSS THE
WORLD.
>> WILL THEY GET THE FRIENDLY
AFGHANS OUT OF THE COUNTRY AND
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE WITHDRAWAL
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
>> FIRST, HAPPY 4th OF JULY AND
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
I SHARE WHAT THE SECRETARY
BENNETT HAS DRAWN.
WE HAVE TO SHOW OUR COMMIT TO
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OF
THOSE TRANSLATORS AND PROVIDE
A SAFE HAVEN AND REFUGE HERE IN
THE U.S.
LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK.
I THINK IT'S HARD TO ARGUE THAT
WE HAVE NOT DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO BRING A DIFFERENT
SECURITY FRAMEWORK TO
AFGHANISTAN.
I HAVE TRAVELED TO AFGHANISTAN
SEVERAL TIMES INCLUDING A FEW
TIMES WITH SENATOR BIDEN AND
SENATOR GRAHAM AND THE LATE
SENATOR MCCANN.
SOME OF THE THINGS THE SECRETARY
RAISED HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED.
MY SENSE IS THEY HAVE.
I HOPE THAT THE WHITE HOUSE --
WHAT I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHETHER OR NOT
A REDLINE HAS BEEN DRAWN ON THE
PART OF THIS ADMINISTRATION,
SAYING IF OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
INTERESTS ARE THREATENED AND IN
THE TALIBAN WHICH IS A ROGUE
GROUP OF TERRORISTS -- 83 PEOPLE
WERE SHOT IN CHICAGO OVER THE
WEEKEND AND 13 KILLED.
WE HAVE ROGUE CRAZY EVERYWHERE.
IN A REDLINE IS COST, I HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE READY TO
GO BACK IN.
THEY ALLOWED A REDLINE TO BE
CROSSED UNDER OBAMA.
WILL THEY NOT ALLOW IT THIS
TIME.
>> TREY GOWDY, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> MIKE, IT'S THE OLD ADAGE.
WE ARE WELCOME TO STOP FIGHTING
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE WAR IS
OVER.
CONGRESSMAN FORD AND DR. BENNETT
RAISED GOOD FORMS.
WE NEED 750 PEOPLE TO PROTECT
OUR EMBASSY IN THE AIRPORT AND
YOU TELL ME THE COUNTRY IS SAFE
FOR AFGHAN WOMEN?
MY FEAR AND HEART BREAK IS
EXPLAINING TO THE AMERICAN SONS
AND DAUGHTERS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES AND LIMBS AND YOUTH IN
THAT COUNTRY, WHAT WAS IT FOR